in arbeiters vielen dank nach bonn ja es
ist die erste sitzungswoche des jahres
20 22 und es ist der erste ganz lange
sitzungstag hier im deutschen bundestag
in diesem jahr bis 20 uhr 30
voraussichtlich werden wir für sie live
dabei sein und die debatten ihnen
übertragen werden können kurz
zurückblicken oft dieselbe zeit vor
ungefähr vier jahren da gab es noch
nicht mal koalitionsverhandlungen
wir älteren erinnern uns natürlich daran
also in dieser woche so eine art kleine
regierungserklärung von den
ministerinnen und ministern mit den
vorhaben zu den kommenden vier jahren
beziehungsweise den vier jahren der
legislaturperiode insgesamt das nennt
sich vereinbarte debatte oder auch
verbundene debatte und es ist und bleibt
ein bisschen was von einer
haushaltswoche wie wir dann aber
wahrscheinlich im märz haben werden da
wird der ältestenrat des bundestags
heute darüber befinden es geht heute um
9 uhr los mit dem ministerium für
klimaschutz
und klimaschutz auch daran müssen wir
uns noch ein klein wenig gewöhnen dass
es hier unter andere bezeichnungen der
ministerien gibt das ministerium also
von robert habeck und er hat am dienstag
schon ein bisschen skizziert in welche
richtung es gehen soll insbesondere beim
klimaschutz mehr tempo mehr flexibilität
mehr aktivität insgesamt und da sind
einige schon zusammengezuckt nicht nur
die das ganze kritisch betrachten
sondern durchaus auch in den eigenen
reihen denn das ganze ist extrem
ambitioniert zumindest das was robert
habeck davor gestellt hat wir werden um
9 ab 9 ungefähr deutlich mehr dazu hören
wir werden aber jetzt schon mal drüber
reden und ich freue mich dass bei uns
sind heute morgen julia verlinken
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen ihnen
einen schönen guten morgen und anja
weisgerber ist bei uns die sprecherin
für umwelt naturschutz nukleare
sicherheit und auch das ein wichtiges
thema im zusammenhang mit klimaschutz
auch verbraucherschutz und sie es
gewesen in der letzten legislaturperiode
die klimaschutzbeauftragte der
unionsfraktion auch ihnen einen schönen
guten morgen frau verlinken ich habe
schon angesprochen dass sich sehr
ambitioniert was robert habeck das
skizziert hat ab wann würden sie sagen
muss man das ganze als erfolg werten
oder und wann welcher stelle muss man
sagen es hat dann doch nicht geklappt
und die messlatte wie ja da aufgestellt
hat ist eigentlich von anfang an zu hoch
gewesen
er hat ja sehr deutlich gemacht wie hoch
er die ausbauzahlen in den nächsten
jahren bei den erneuerbaren energien
forciert und damit hat er sich natürlich
auch sehr klar positioniert und ich
denke mal sie alle werden als
journalistin dann natürlich auch
nachfragen ob es geklappt hat oder nicht
aber es bleibt uns ja nichts anderes
übrig wir haben schweres erbe übernommen
von der vorgängerregierung die viel zu
langsam war beim klimaschutz wir haben
einen extrem rückstau und deswegen
müssen wir das tempo jetzt umso mehr
erhöhen und das erwarten die wählerinnen
und wähler von uns und das erwarten
glaube ich auch die menschen wie seit
vielen jahren auch für mehr klimaschutz
demonstrieren naja die frau verließ man
sich ja wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
vorbereitet auf das was er am dienstag
in der pressekonferenz war aber haben
sie auch gedacht ob es ist schon ein
großes ein sehr sehr großes ziel und es
wird anstrengend das umzusetzen
selbstverständlich wird es anstrengend
und deswegen brauchen wir auch alle wir
brauchen die gesellschaft die insgesamt
auch mitmach wir brauchen menschen die
investieren die die arbeitskräfte im zur
verfügung stellen und selbstverständlich
ja noch mitmachen es braucht
insbesondere auch die länder und die
kommunen das wird eine herausforderung
die wir als deutschland insgesamt
bewältigen müssen und ich bin aber
dankbar dafür dass jetzt die regierung
sich vorgenommen hat die entsprechenden
politischen rahmenbedingungen dafür zu
schaffen damit das auch gelingen kann
damit die menschen investieren können
und damit weniger bürokratie gibt auf
dem weg dorthin wobei die
rahmenbedingungen wahrscheinlich schon
eine herausforderung ganz eigener natur
sein werden frau weiß gelmer schon
gesagt dass die klimaschutzbeauftragte
gewesen sind der unionsfraktion in der
vergangenen legislaturperiode diesen
posten diese position gibt es nicht mehr
warum mich weil es einen klima ausschuss
gibt und einen klimapolitischen sprecher
das ist andreas jung er hat die
klimapolitik mit mir zusammen für die
cdu gemacht ich auch für die
gesamtfraktion und die csu ich bin jetzt
umweltpolitische sprecherin auch im
umweltausschuss ist nach wie vor die
klimaanpassung und auch die natürliche
klimapolitik enthalten gemeinsam machen
wir den geschmack kreis weiter in der
fraktion und arbeiten dass ihr eng und
gut zusammen also kein zeichen dafür
dass das thema nicht mehr für wichtig
erachtet wird sondern einfach was mit
umstrukturierungen zu tun hat nur noch
mit der veränderten zuständigkeiten muss
man ja gelegentlich auch mal dazu sagen
wir haben robert habeck gehört wir haben
auch gehört was frau verlinken eben
gesagt hat das ist kein besonders gutes
zeugnis dass robert habeck der
vorgängerregierung ausgestellt hat
obwohl sie selber ja immer gesagt haben
wir haben eine menge getan für den
klimaschutz passt jetzt nicht so richtig
zusammen auf den ersten blick wir haben
220 die klimaziele erreicht und zwar zu
einem großen teil aufgrund unserer
instrumente die wir auf den weg gebracht
haben und auch den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien aber den letzten
zehn jahren verdoppelt ja wir sind auch
dafür und wir werden konstruktive
oppositionspolitik machen dass wir den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien weiter
forcieren aber das ganze muss
funktionieren zu stabilen preisen und
die energieversorgungssicherheit muss
weiterhin gewährleistet werden und da
gilt es auch realistisch an das thema
heranzugehen zur wahrheit gehört doch
die bürgerinnen und bürger und auch die
unternehmen die echten im moment unter
den sehr hohen energiepreisen und zur
wahrheit gehört auch dass wir weiterhin
die gaskraftwerke als brückentechnologie
als übergangs aktivität brauchen und das
müssen sich die grünen an der stelle
auch mal ehrlich machen und da muss auch
die rahmenbedingungen müssen so sein
dass man da rein investiert jetzt müssen
gucken dass mit waren ganz viele punkte
die sich jetzt auch angesprochen haben
müssen wir gucken dass das ist mir ein
bisschen auseinander nehmen systematisch
unter oder hintereinander auch gucken
frau verliebt und hat den kopf
geschüttelt schon bei der frage als sie
gesagt habe wir haben die klimaziele 20
20 20 erreicht haben sie den kopf
geschüttelt warum ja weil sich die
wissenschaft einig ist dass da sehr
viele corona effekte mit eingerechnet
werden müssen um zu erklären warum dann
überraschenderweise doch dieses ziel
erreicht worden ist wir haben jetzt für
20 21 müssen wir damit rechnen dass wenn
die endgültigen zahlen vorliegen das ist
verfehlt worden ist und das ist
zurückzuführen auf die politik der
letzten 16 jahre also insofern man wenn
man sich allein die ausbauzahlen für
solaranlagen und für windkraftanlagen
anschaut dann ist sind diese mengen
deutlich zurückgegangen in den letzten
jahren und das ist auch zurückzuführen
auf die politik von herrn altmaier und
da würde ich einen punkt noch mit dazu
gegeben bevor sie antworten frau
weisgerber strom aus erneuerbaren
energien liegt derzeit bei ungefähr 42
prozent anteil
stromerzeugung das tiefe 2030 ist aber
80 prozent das heißt muss jetzt
innerhalb von knapp acht jahren noch mal
derselbe pensum schaffen was bislang
über mehrere jahre fast jahrzehnte
erreicht worden ist wie soll das gehen
aus ihrer sicht ist ja nicht doch
verschlechtert was verschlafen worden
gerade was den ausbau der windenergie
gerade bei ihnen in bayern angeht wir
brauchen planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
wichtig wir brauchen auch eine starke
bürgerbeteiligung wir wollen auch den
ausbau forcieren aber mit den bürgern
und nicht gegen sie und dann gehe ich
gerne auf das thema windkraft ein weil
das ist ja der hauptkritikpunkt zur
wahrheit gehört dass der wind ausbau in
ganz deutschland stagniert ist und frau
verdienten als erfahrene energie
politikern wissen sie ja auch dass das
insbesondere auch daran liegt dass im
norden deutschlands wir flache
landschaften haben dass da der wind
stärker weht dass dort die
windkraftanlagen auch lukrativer
betrieben werden können im unterschied
zum süden deutschlands und da ist es zum
beispiel auch so dass in baden
württemberg der ausbau unter ihrem grüne
ministerpräsident kretschmann auch
stagniert ist und das liegt daran dass
die rahmenbedingungen ausschreibungen
unbedingt geändert werden müssen das
heißt wir brauchen eine süd quote wir
brauchen einen vorrang in den
ausschreibungen und eine feste quote von
15 prozent das für diese 15 prozent
anlagen im süden deutschland zum zuge
kommen und da haben sie jetzt enorme
hausaufgaben all das müssen sie
gegenüber der eu kommission durchsetzen
wir haben das schon sehr sehr stark
angemahnt das ist jetzt einfach aufgrund
der neuen regierungsbildung jetzt im
endeffekt vertagt worden da müssen wir
ansetzen und wir brauchen eine stärkere
finanzielle beteiligung der bürgerinnen
und bürger auch das haben wir schon auf
den weg gebracht das muss verstärkt
werden also der super gau wäre für mich
wenn wir im endeffekt jetzt durch eine
pauschale abschaffung der
abstandsflächen im endeffekt die bürger
in vielen regionen deutschlands
verbringen und dann auf der anderen
seite die eigentliche ursache die ich
gerade beschrieben haben nicht behoben
ist frau fällen gerne direkt ja ich habe
es ja gerade selber schon gesagt im um
den ausbau in allen teilen von
deutschland bei der windenergie
voranzubringen ist es notwendig eben
auch bundespolitische rahmen zu
verändern und das ist in den letzten
jahren versäumt worden das packen wir
jetzt gerne an und haben uns dazu auch
verpflichtet weil wir das natürlich
wichtig finden das auch die höhenzüge
hätten sie mich im süden von deutschland
natürlich auch ihre potenziale entfalten
und dort natürlich auch mit energie
ernten sozusagen das thema bürgerenergie
sind ganz ganz wichtig ist hat die eu
uns ganz klare hausaufgaben als
mitgliedsstaat auf den weg gegeben viele
von den erwartungen die eigentlich
hätten schon umgesetzt werden müssen bis
ende juni sind nicht erfolgt das heißt
der altmaier hat diese punkte für eine
stärkere bürgerbeteiligung bei der
energiewende nicht umgesetzt und umso
mehr hausaufgaben haben wir jetzt zu tun
sie hat jetzt pauschal von den
rahmenbedingungen gesprochen die wir auf
bundesebene
angeblich nicht gut angegangen werden
die finanzielle beteiligung die ich
gemeint habe die muss im endeffekt jetzt
auch genutzt werden das heißt wenn in
einer gemeinde eine windkraftanlage
gebaut wird und die kann man ja auch
schon jetzt zum beispiel uns in bayern
in abweichung von 10h mit einer
geringeren abstandsfläche bauen zunahme
ist man ganz gut mal wieder erläutern
kommunen auch beteiligt werden können
sie gleich weiter ausbilden ich wollte
nur gerade zehn jahren noch mal im
aufnehmen und erklären 10h also die 10h
regelung in bayern die mit hat ist die
abstandsregelung zwischen wohnbebauung
und ab da wo windräder windkraftanlagen
aufgebaut werden sollen zählen habe dort
das zehnfache der höhe einer solchen
einer solchen anlage der liegt der
mittelwert glaube ich wenn ich es
richtig gelesen habe bei 160 metern kann
man sich ausrechnen sind mindestens
anderthalb kilometern abstand das ist
schon relativ viel und ist glaube ich
auch deutschlandweit der meister oder
der höchste wert insgesamt die
vereinigung der bayerischen wirtschaft
habe ich heute morgen bei den kollegen
der süddeutschen zeitung entnommen die
kritisieren diesen droht diese hohen
abstandsregelungen weil sie sagen damit
kommen wir nicht zu dem ziel das wir
eigentlich erreichen wollen und da
können sich jetzt wieder einsetzen ich
möchte noch einmal betonen dass auch in
bayern auch jetzt schon eine abweichung
von 10h nach unten möglich ist dass wir
in der öffentlichkeit immer überhaupt
nicht kommuniziert und da gilt es die
bürgerinnen und bürger und die kommunen
mitzunehmen und die chance steckt in der
finanziellen beteiligungsmöglichkeit
dass man im endeffekt den kommunen auch
jetzt sagen kann übrigens auch bei
freiflächen photovoltaikanlagen haben
wir das auf den weg gebracht wenn ihr
diese windkraftanlage akzeptiert auch
vielleicht mit einem geringeren abstand
dann profitiert die kommune dann können
die einnahmen zum beispiel in die
kindergärten in die kommunalen
einrichtungen fließen da steckt der
schlüssel drin und ich möchte noch mal
sagen vorrang für erneuerbare energien
bedeutet für uns nicht das auf dem
rücken der bürgerinnen und bürger zu
machen wir müssen es gemeinsam mit ihnen
machen und ganz interessant ist auch das
thema artenschutz ist es eine
konfliktlinie die ich gerne auf machen
würde aber ich wollte nicht so gerne
weil wir sonst irgendwie den faden
verlieren und weil das andere eigentlich
noch ganz interessant genug ist und ich
frau verliebt noch fragen wollte es tut
sich offenbar in bayern was wenn man
sich anhört was frau weisgerber gerade
gesagt hat dass die ausnahmeregelungen
bei der bei der abstandsregelung also da
ist ja offenbar gesprächsmöglichkeit
oder gesprächs ansätze da ja ich hoffe
dass die gespräche zwischen robert
habeck und der landesregierung da zum
erfolg führen weil wenn es so ist das
wirklich auch bayern sich dem
klimaschutz ernsthaft widmen möchte im
sinne von das auch klar wird dass wir
auch dort windräder bauen müssen weil
man muss einfach de facto sagen es sind
in den letzten jahren kaum welche in
bayern neu entstanden also insofern
scheint ja die 10h regelung doch eine
verhinderungs regelung zu sein für neue
windkraftanlagen und ich hoffe sehr dass
diese gespräche zum erfolg führen ich
hoffe sehr dass auch die bayerische
regierung sich dazu verpflichtet jetzt
hier mehr tempo zu machen weil diese
verantwortung auch verlässliche
stromversorgung in bayern zu ermöglichen
die scheint ja auch nicht als relevant
zu sein der letzte anmerkung sei mir
erlaubt wir sind den dreien sonnenland
wir sind führend in allen anderen
erneuerbaren energien wir haben allein
im photovoltaik-bereich an den zubau
gehabt von einem viertel von ganz
deutschland im jahr 2020 und das liegt
eben daran dass in bayern
windkraftanlagen nicht so wirtschaftlich
betrieben werden können wie im norden
deutschlands und das ist in baden
württemberg genauso und noch mal auch in
baden württemberg wo es keine 10h
regelung gibt die hat der ausbau
stagniert also liegt die ursache in der
beschriebenen süd quote und wir werden
forcieren gerade markus söder ist bei
dem klima themen sehr forsch voran
gegangen er hat sich sogar weiter gehen
ziele gesetzt in manchen punkten als der
bund und deswegen bin ich sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir in dieser
gespräche konstruktiv gehen werden auch
beim thema repowering zum beispiel wenn
schon anlagen da sind kann man auch über
die 10h regelung reden aber der
grundsatz der sollte erhalten bleiben
mit den bürgern und nicht gegen sie wir
könnten hier locker noch eine halbe
stunde wandern machen aber wir haben wir
überhaupt nicht mehr weil in 23 minuten
das plenum beginnen deswegen eine frage
zum abschluss noch an sie beide auch die
eu-kommission will kommen nicht drum rum
sagt er jetzt dass atomenergie
möglicherweise bis 20.45 genehmigte
anlagen dazu beitragen könnten den co2
ausstoß deutlich zu verringern bei der
energiegewinnung sind wir zu früh
ausgestiegen aus der atomenergie oder
zweite frage gleich noch mit dazu
irgendwie sind die finnischen grünen die
ja bekanntermaßen für diese variante
sind zumindest vorübergehend nicht grün
genug oder haben sie etwas nicht
verstanden nein atomkraft ist eine
hochrisikotechnologie atomkraft ist viel
zu teuer und atomkraft hilft uns nicht
beim klimaschutz deswegen ist es ein
fehler dass die eu kommission jetzt
vorschlägt atomkraft als nachhaltig zu
klassifizieren für finanzmarktprodukte
und
dagegen haben sich auch alle
regierungsvertreter aus deutschland
bisher ausgesprochen auch noch mal eine
frau war es ganz kurz x 20m fehler der
atomausstieg nach dem unglück in
fukushima wir haben uns mit breiten
mehrheiten dafür entschieden aber ich
möchte an der stelle schon sagen der
energiemix in den mitgliedsstaaten der
eu ist unterschiedlich organisiert
raus aus der kernenergie raus aus der
kohle und weg vom gas das kann nicht in
allen mitgliedstaaten gleichzeitig
funktionieren und gerade auch nicht in
deutschland als energieintensives land
das auf stromimporte angewiesen ist wir
brauchen den energiebinnenmarkt und wir
brauchen auch gas als
übergangstechnologie
und da müssen die rahmenbedingungen
ebenso seien im rahmen der taxonomie das
da rein investiert wird denn das
brauchen wir für die
energieversorgungssicherheit und für den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland und was
das gas als übergangstechnologie angeht
hat ja auch steffi lemke die
umweltministerin gesagt müssen wir
wahrscheinlich eine zeitlang tatsächlich
darauf zurückgreifen vor weisgerber frau
verliehen vielen dank für das
konstruktive gespräch hier heute morgen
ich habe da viel spaß und hätte gerne
weitergemacht geht aber nicht also in
vielen dank weil sie müssen sich jetzt
auch reingehen